these are my disclosures and the clock is already ticking so i gotta okay so with that in mind you
guys all know this stuff so i'll try not to dwell on things that you do know which is that the kind
of general treatment approach for aml has not changed in a very long time we largely look at
fitness of patients fit patients get more intensive therapy unfit patients get less
intensive therapy and this has been rock stable solid data that has guided therapy for decades
probably five decades in fact on this stage three years ago i debated with eunice wang
should our standard be seven and three we now actually have data that is starting to change
this big paradigm i'll talk about that in this talk what is new in 2026 rapid genomics really
is a thing we can do this on the myelomatch study increasingly people can do this at their own
institutions this is driving treatment this is potentially changing what we do as frontline
therapy so whether you even give intensive chemotherapy can be changed based on
data that comes back in days we can fully genotype a patient at our institution within
three days of them walking in the door which is remarkable and we're now doing that on trials to
say this is the right trial therapy for the patient as well and hopefully defining new
treatment approaches mrd monitoring of aml is now updated in uh in blood from the elm
nice to have the updates and these are much more practical than the last version so please look at
these and there's two new agents which will be talked about in the uh upcoming sessions
so i will only dwell on them
briefly okay what is myelomatch we will have talks on this in terms of how has the first
year or so of myelomatch gone this is an nci precision medicine initiative
to get patients rapidly genotyped on again a rapid
ngs panel that turns around in three days a full karyotype and fish testing for anything we can't
get by the above methods so that basically you can get a risk stratification of the full genotype of
the leukemia within essentially three business days of walking in the door uh a group of
patients in the lab and then we assigns a patient to a study and then we start answering randomized
questions um they're signal finding studies they are not you know definitive answers but
they're ways to quickly move regimens through quickly as in quotes here um uh through development
at a cooperative group level so that we can hopefully also gather a lot of samples for
correlative science which will also happen this is the basic design of the entire program right now
there are only tier one studies but the goal is to have this follow the patient through their whole
body from diagnosis potentially to mrd positivity and or relapse for patients who go on for transplant
and to develop novel assays with next generation sequencing to guide further validation and
incorporation into future treatment approaches these are some of the studies that are open and
hopefully you guys are already enrolling people to these or no colleagues who are doing the same
so i do want to talk a little bit about the paradigm study which
was a plenary at ash so you may have seen this a little bit
um this is poised to be kind of the david and goliath uh lineup here as shown on the left or
maybe vanesa is the little engine that could this is challenging the dictum that we have to use an
intensive chemotherapy backbone for every newly diagnosed patient walking in the door
and what i hope everybody didn't walk away from this study was that this is
every aml patient who walks in the door because it really is not we were really
careful to just select the patients for whom seven and three only or cpx only would have been the
preferred standard therapy and so if you look at the exclusion criteria here um basically anybody
with uh eln favorable disease certainly uh npm1 mutant patients under the age of 60 or core binding
factor we didn't allow apl patients those patients were excluded also excluded were patients with a
flip 3 mutation for a therapy so it's basically everybody else and in general these are the
patients that we think need to get induction therapy get a response to their disease go on to
transplant and that that would be definitive therapy so it's how do we get from point a to
point b as part of curative therapy um and what the study showed first off looking at it this is
basically who we enrolled the median age was 65 this is what we see there was a big age range
including people up in their 70s um they were primarily eln adverse risk and and i should also
say with the median age of 64 um 40 of the patients were under the age of 60 so the folks
that would go on all the studies that you know of intensive chemotherapy um and there were no favor
herbal risk patients under the age of 60 on the study and nearly everybody was a ps of zero or one
indicating they were indeed fit for this therapy again the goal was transplant and cr1 and for
pretty much every metric that we looked at in terms of response uh objective responses as
defined by the protocol composite cr um cr crh also crcri um the cr rates are actually pretty similar
um but in no situation was venetoclax worse um and actually when we look at transplantation
rates they were better in the aza ven arm and the event-free survival which was the the primary
endpoint of the study was also favorable in the uh uh venezia arm okay the survival was the same um
we did not predict that this would be different by virtue of the fact that we knew this was an open
label study and that patients could cross over and in point of fact they did the majority of patients
on the intensive chemotherapy arm of the study did actually get venezia as part of their salvage
approach on second line therapy um this sort of negates the whole ability to look for an overall
survival benefit when you have effective salvage regimens um for this is kind of the key thing here
we also knew going into the study if it were the same it would still kind of be a win for veneza
because we thought it was going to be easier on patients and indeed it was
for every metric we thought was important um in incidents of severe toxicities
60-day mortality which was zero in the venezia arm uh hospital utilization venezia
blew away uh intensive chemotherapy half the hospitalization duration no icu admissions
um so this is important in terms of this being easier therapy for the patients and it also worked
better um these are the elm mrd guidance and i don't think we actually have a specific talk on
this but i would recommend you read the publication which is now out in blood and
it's important because it's much more practical than previous versions and i can hear andy
zelenetz who i think is not at this meeting this year um echoing my ear saying you know when you say
mrd positive by what assay at what time point it includes that and that's the key thing there's mrd
and then there's mrd and this uses the kind of cml traffic light analogy for how do we interpret uh
mrd is this something that is a warning sign and we can kind of monitor it or it's a really high
risk the patient's about to relapse this gives you guidance on how to use the uh the data from your
mrd okay and then importantly this is the first time we've had flip3 FLT3 mrd which you should be
using um and there is no defined
warning signal for this any mrd is bad um so lastly i'll just throw out that menin inhibitors
are here and approved uh approved in npm1 mutant disease for zift amenib and an mpm1 mutant disease
for or kmt2a rearranged disease for revumenib currently only approved as single agents in
relapsed refractory patients soon to be coming we hope based on randomized studies
is that these drugs may show what we've seen with other target inhibitors like plethrin
inhibitors that perhaps they are actually going to improve survival um so those studies are actually
in uh uh enrollment right now because the preliminary data from single arm studies is so
strong um these are all the data with seven and three and zift amenib uh these are the data with
uh multiple other men and inhibitors in combination with van aza um please enroll
your patients to these studies these are going to be important in practice defining um so in
conclusion it's a great time in the aml world there are major changes in the treatment approach
mrd monitoring is now a thing you can do this with commercial laboratories so you can send
this on your own patients men and inhibitors are here and look like they are here to stay
and we will see just how effective they are going forward thanks very much for your